y todos los ejemplos de comunicación
célula célula que hemos visto hasta
ahora han sido de células dentro de un
solo organismo pero lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es señalar que también se
puede tener comunicación célula célula
entre distintos organismos incluso entre
distintos organismos unicelulares
entonces lo que tenemos aquí son
imágenes de células de levadura las
levaduras son organismos eucariontes
unicelulares lo que significa que tienen
un núcleo y son oficialmente hongos lo
que ven que está sucediendo en esta
imagen de aquí parece que tenemos una
segunda célula de levadura producto de
la creación de la primera esto pasa
fundamentalmente por mitosis pero las
levaduras pueden reproducirse en dos
maneras diferentes se reproducen
asexualmente por mitosis como aquí pero
también se pueden reproducir sexualmente
y eso es de lo que vamos a hablar un
poco
hablaremos de comunicación entre las
células quienes se comunican a través de
los factores de apareamiento y esto es
sólo una discusión interesante acerca de
levaduras en general entonces si
empezamos con la célula de la levadura
esta es una célula de la levadura justo
aquí y esta es una célula
hoy
de levadura así que tiene su complemento
de cromosomas completo va a tener 16
pares
de cromosomas o 32 cromosomas en total
eso es un display de entonces a través
de la mitosis se puede separar y lo hace
así la que separada para la mayoría de
las especies de levaduras será más
pequeña pero hay algunas que hacen una
mitosis más uniforme pero por mitosis se
pueden producir
dos células diploides de levadura justo
como éstas entonces todos estos
caracteres todos estos caracteres justo
aquí son diploides y en realidad dado
que son eucariontes tienen una pequeña
membrana nuclear aquí adentro pero
también pueden dividirse por medio sis
entonces esto justo aquí es
mitosis con lo que se produjeron estas
dos células pero también podrían
producirse por meiosis me dio
y si experimentan meiosis van a producir
4 células y lo interesante acerca de
esto es que estas tendrán se van a
convertir en uno o dos tipos y puedes
ver esto como el sexo de estas células
de levadura entonces pueden estar en el
tipo
hagamos estas dos tipo
entonces esta es tipo a y esta es tipo a
justo aquí o bien puede ser tipo alfa
entonces esto es un tipo usaré un color
distinto entonces esta es tipo alfa
esta otra es otra tipo alfa y las cuatro
se producen por medio sis de esta célula
originalmente diploide y como
experimentaron meiosis cada una de éstas
va a ser a floyd entonces todas ellas
van a ser a plate es entonces todas
estas van a ser a floyd es con 16
cromosomas en total 16 cro
más
cada una de ellas y todas van a hacer
hoy
y de hecho cada una de ellas hasta
cierto punto puede vivir una vida propia
y continuar reproduciéndose por mitosis
eso es lo que estamos resaltando lo que
es interesante uno no asociar ya células
sexuales en el caso de los humanos uno
no pensaría que los espermatozoides son
capaces de reproducirse por sí mismos o
que los óvulos se pueden reproducir por
sí mismos pero en el caso de las
levaduras ellas realmente pueden hacerlo
entonces esta célula tipo a puede
convertirse por mitosis en dos células
tipo a
esto es solo el transfondo y es muy
interesante mi todo
entonces los productos de la meiosis
pueden reproducirse por sí mismos por
mitosis todo esto es interesante y todo
esto es el planteamiento para pensar
cómo es que realmente se comunican
porque estás células a floyd es que son
producidas como un producto de la
meiosis
todas estas de aquí provienen de nuestra
célula progenitora lo que es bastante
común hablando de reproducción o pseudo
reproducción sexual de células de
levadura pero ellas no tienen que
hacerlo tal vez una de las tipo alfa
proviene de otro ancestro lo que sucede
es que en cada liberación de los que son
llamados factores de apareamiento que
pueden ser considerados feromonas de
apareamiento
esta célula tipo a de aquí va a producir
los factores de apareamiento tipo a va a
liberarlos en el espacio que la rodea
está liberando esos factores de
apareamiento tipo a y las células alfa
van a liberar factores de apareamiento
tipo alfa los dibujaré
el color café liberarán los factores de
apareamiento tipo alfa y lo que pasa es
que cada tipo de célula tiene receptores
de la otra variedad de factores
entonces la célula tipo a va a tener
receptores para el tipo alfa que van a
estar en todo el exterior de la célula
tipo a en la célula tipo alfa va a tener
receptores del tipo a receptores los
dibujaré de naranja va a tener
receptores
va a tener receptores para los tipos los
vamos a dibujar así no es exactamente
como son pero es parecido nos da la idea
de las cosas y a través de estos
receptores empiezan a enlazar muchas
digamos que estamos en la célula alfa
justo aquí empiezan a enlazarse con
estas feromonas de apareamiento estos
factores de apareamiento después la
célula de levadura tal cual no se mueve
pero empieza a crecer en esa dirección
empieza a crecer en la dirección en la
que dice hey
estoy sintiendo muchos factores de
apareamiento y empieza a crecer en esta
dirección toma una forma parecida a ésta
y sucede lo mismo con las células de
levadura tipo a va a tener los factores
alfa unidos a ella y por esta razón dice
ok estoy sintiendo y una vez más los
factores se mantienen unidos a los
receptores qué es
parte sensible y va a tener transducción
de señales y en realidad no es muy
distinto a la vía marca de transducción
de la que se habló en otros vídeos y
como respuesta está célula tiene que
empezar a crecer de nuevo en la
dirección en la que provienen estos
factores de apareamiento
y este tipo de elongación este
crecimiento de las células de levadura
proyde que se llama en realidad como
esto justo aquí es un exmo
y de dónde viene ese término pues viene
de este dibujo de aquí que es el
personaje de una caricatura de mediados
del siglo 20 y era bueno vamos a evitar
cualquier clase de risitas durante el
vídeo pero así es como se ve
el crecimiento de la una hacia la otra
les permite unirse y formar otra célula
diploide de levadura así que si este
proceso continúa
estas dos seísmos se unen y la
composición genética también se une y es
posible obtener otra célula diploide
esta célula diploide va a tener una
nueva combinación de adn y puede
beneficiarse por esta variación para la
reproducción sexual esta es
hoy
aunque para células de levadura y me
gusta estudiarlo porque no es claro que
provengan de patrimonios genéticos
separados en realidad podrían provenir
de una misma molécula progenitora es una
pregunta abierta en biología el por qué
tienen este tipo de reproducción sexual
especialmente si vienen de de si son
células hermanas y producto de una
meiosis pero bueno todo el punto de esto
es uno apreciar estos fascinantes
procesos que suceden al nivel celular de
las levaduras y que existe comunicación
célula célula no solo dentro de
organismos sino a través de distintos
organismos especialmente o incluso
organismos unicelulares